the head of the Environmental Protection
Agency is expected to announce today
that he believes water safety is a
bigger environmental crisis than climate
change
only on CBS News EPA Administrator
andrew wheeler spoke with major Garrett
in his first interview since being
confirmed major good morning good
morning the Senate confirmed wheeler
last month not a single Democrat
supported him in general Republicans
support his deregulatory agenda at the
EPA and the economic benefits they say
it brings Democrats and environmental
say whatever the economic benefits new
environmental risks will be posed by
that deregulatory agenda and they accuse
wheeler of refusing to take action on
climate change the drinking water today
worldwide is probably the biggest
environmental threat we have if I hear
you correctly you're saying all of this
tension energy politics over on climate
change is essentially misguided we have
1,000 children die every day worldwide
because they don't have safe drinking
water that's a that's a crisis that I
think we can solve most of the threats
from climate change or 50 to 75 years
out what we need to do is make sure that
the people who are dying today from lack
of having drinking water in third world
countries that problem is addressed
wheeler wants to drive a global debate
on clean water even though water woes
continue here at home in Flint Michigan
and elsewhere Baltimore Milwaukee Newark
Chicago Detroit said he's not named
Flint also have deep problems with
public water supply I want to make sure
the American public understands 92
percent of the water every day meets all
the EPA requirements for safe drinking
water what can you tell people and those
impacted areas is going to change under
your watch and give them a greater sense
of confidence about the water either
they consume where their children
consider again 92 percent of the water
in the country that's cold comfort all
of our know that standard is high I
realize that but we're no good for
anyone who lives in Flint Michigan
what does because we've been working
with flat wheeler supports president
Trump's thirty percent budget cut to the
EPA and his downplaying of the climate
change threat is sure to anger Democrats
climate change is not a
but is a massive unprecedented threat
you hear Democrats running for the
nomination in 2020 say or in a
catastrophic situation is anything
unreasonable about those impressions yes
I think it is unreasonable all the
environmental indicators continue to get
better
air pollution did decrease here in the
United States from 2005 to 2007 teen but
it rose last year as far as clean water
government investigators have told the
EPA that cities routinely miss report
then cover up their lack of compliance
with clean water standards making that
92 percent figure less reliable than it
sounds and environmentalists warn that
deregulatory actions taken at the EPA
biana
could increase water pollution not
decrease it major there's no doubt this
is going to be a big campaign issue for
Democrats thank you